[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la Camarde qui ne m'a jamais pardonné
d'avoir semé des fleurs dans les trous
de son nez me poursuit d'un zel imbécile
[Musique]
alors cerné de près par les enterrements
j'ai cru bon de remettre à jour mon
testament de me payer un
[Musique]
codicile trempe dans l'encre bleu du
Golfe du Lion trempe trempe ta plume mon
vieux tellon et de ta plus belle
écriture
note ce qu'il faudrait qu'il abain de
mon corps lorsque mon âme et lui ne
seront plus d'accord que sur un seul
point la
rupture quand mon âme aura pris son vol
à l'horizon vers celle de Gavroche et de
Mimi Pinon celle des titis des
grisettes
que vers le sol natal mon corps soit
ramené dans un slieping du Paris
Méditérranée terminus en gare de
7 mon caveau de famille h làas ce n'est
pas tout neuf vulgairement parlant il
est plein comme un uf et d'ici que
quelqu'un en
sorte
il risque de se faire tarer je ne peux
dire à ces braves gens poussez-vous donc
un peu place aux jeunes en quelque
[Musique]
sorte juste au bord de la mer à de pas
des flots bleus creuser si c'est
possible un petit trou moelleux une
bonne petite
niche auprès de mes amis d'enfance les
dauphins le long de cette grève où le
sable est si fin sur la plage de la
Corniche c'est une plage où même à ses
moments furieux Neptune ne se prend
jamais trop au sérieux ou quand un
bateau fait
naufrage le capitaine criit je suis le
maître à bord sauve qui peut le vin et
le pastisse d'abord chacun savon bonne
et
[Musique]
courage et c'est là que jadis à 15 ans
révolu à la joue s'amuser tout seul ne
suffit plus je connu la
pramourette auprès d'une sirène une
femme poisson je reçu de l'amour la
première leçon avaler la première
arrête déférence gardé envers Paul
Valérie moi l'umble troubadour sur lui
je
renchéri le bon maître me le
[Musique]
pardonne et com moin si sévère va le
mieux que les miens mon cimetière soit
plus marin que le sien et n' déplaise
aux
autochtones est-ce trop demandé sur mon
petit lopain plantez je vous en prie une
espèce de pain pain parasol de
[Musique]
préférence qui saura prémunir contre
l'insolation les bons amis venus faire
sur ma
concession
d'affectueuse
révérence cette tombe en sandwich entre
le ciel et l'eau ne donnera pas une
ombre triste au tableau mais un charme
[Musique]
indéfinissable les baigneuses s'en
serviront de paravant pour changer de
tenue et les petits enfants liront
chouette un château de
[Musique]
sable tantôt venant d'Espagne et tantôt
d'Italie tout chargé de parfum de
musique jolie le mistral et la
tramontane sur mon dernier sommeil
verseront les échos de vilanelle un jour
un jour de
fendango de tarantelle de
[Musique]
Sardan et qu'en prenant ma bute en guise
d'oreiller une nonine viendra gentiment
sommeiller avec moins que rien de
costume j'en demande pardon par avance
Jésus si l'ombre de ma croix s'y couche
un peu dessus pour un petit bonheur
[Musique]
posture pauvre roi pharaon pauvre
Napoléon pauvre grand disparu lisant au
Panthéon pauvre cendre de
[Musique]
conséquence vous envirez un peu
l'Éternel
qui fait du pédalau sur la vague en
rêvant qui passe sa mort en
[Musique]
vacance vous envirez un peu l'Éternel
estivan qui fait du pédalau sur la vague
en rêvant qui passe sa mort en
[Musique]
vacances